So, if you're struggling to grow on
YouTube, and you're struggling to get
views on YouTube, and you want to build
your personal brand or your business on
YouTube, this video is for you.
My channel is about to hit 200,000
subscribers in just 12 months. And I've
been on YouTube since 2009. During this
time, I built multiple channels. I've
helped multiple creators grow their
channels, and I have learned a lot. In
this video, as some sort of celebration
of hitting 200,000 subscribers on this
channel, almost hitting 200,000
subscribers, I wanted to make this kind
of raw video where I don't edit the
video at all, maybe just cuts, and
that's it. And what I want to talk about
in this video is everything I have
learned about YouTube. And not just
YouTube, but about the internet in
general, because growing on YouTube is
not just about learning how YouTube
works. It's actually more about learning
how the internet works, how people's
mind work on the internet, and stuff
like that. So, it's way deeper than just
click-through rate and thumbnails and
video editing and whatever. Now, as I've
said, I've been on YouTube since 2009.
That's when I created my first YouTube
channel, actually my first three
channels. Now, none of these channels
had any success. This was just me
fooling around and playing with YouTube
and dreaming about becoming rich and
famous and changing my life and these
channels are going to change my life.
That's what I used to think at the time.
I think one channel had like 80
subscribers. The other channel had like
500 subscribers, and the other channel,
I don't even remember. And the reason
one of the channels had 500 subscribers
is because back then, there was this
trend where you could go to popular
channels and go to their popular videos
and comment sub for sub, and people
would just subscribe to you and you
would subscribe back. And I used to do
that. I would wake up in the morning, go
to a popular video and just type sub for
sub, and I would get two subscribers
that day. And I would do that every
single day until I reached 500
subscribers. And what's funny is that I
really believed that this is going to
make me rich. Like I found the secret.
I'm just going to do this until I get 1
million subscribers and I'm going to be
rich. I really believed that at the
time, you know, I was just a teenager.
So, spoiler alert, it didn't work. The
channel is stuck at 500 subscribers. And
by the way, if you do this today,
YouTube is going to terminate your
channel. This is against YouTube's
policy. So, you're not allowed to do sub
for sub. So, don't do sub for sub,
especially because it makes no sense.
You You're getting subscribers who don't
care about you. But, I just wanted to
share this memory because I think it's
valuable to understand why him and where
I come from. But, as time passed, I have
learned more and more about YouTube and
more about the internet. And that's when
I created my first successful channel
called Dub Step Gutter. You can go ahead
and search for it. I'm going to leave a
screenshot over here. This is a faceless
channel. It's a music brand channel and
a label. And there's even a video with
myself on the channel. Back then, I
didn't have tattoos, like neck tattoos,
but you can see the similarity. That's
literally me on the channel. So, that
was the first successful channel I've
created and it has a 6 million
subscribers right now. Now, after I
created this channel, I have created two
more music channels, one animation
channel, and two documentary channels.
They're all faceless. And I personally
prefer to keep them private. Not only
that, but besides these faceless
channels, I've also created two vlogs
channels. Now, all of these channels are
and have been quite successful. But, you
have to understand, it took more than 10
years to grow them. So, growing all
these channels wasn't something that
happened overnight. And during this
period of more than 10 years of building
different channels in different niches
and working with different creators, I
have learned a lot about YouTube, about
the internet, and about how people's
minds work when it comes to spending
time online. This is also one of the
reasons why this channel you're watching
right now, Danny Wy, has grown to almost
200,000 subscribers in less than 12
months. Now, for some of you, 200,000
subscribers might not seem like a lot,
but given the niche I'm in, which is
educational, the people who watch my
videos are not kids and they're not
teenagers. So, I'm going to share the
analytics on the screen of my viewers
average age. Not only that, but the
people who subscribed to my channel
usually have millions of subscribers.
For example, I'm going to share over
here the analytics of some people who
are subscribed to Danny Wy. So, what I'm
trying to say is that 200,000
subscribers in my niche is a lot of
subscribers. And by the way, the reason
why I'm showing you all of this is not
to flex on you, is simply to show you
who I am and what I've done. Because as
I've said in the beginning of this
video, the purpose of this video is to
help you grow your YouTube channel, your
personal brand on YouTube, or your
business on YouTube. And I just wanted
to make sure you understand that I know
what I'm talking about. With that said,
let me show you everything I know about
growing on YouTube and all the mistakes
I've made and all the mistakes I see
other people make and so on. It's going
to be a pretty long video, so you might
watch it as a podcast, as a one-person
podcast. Watch it while you're driving,
while you're eating, before you go to
bed. So, let's begin. I want to start
off with the biggest mistake I have made
and I see other people make over and
over and over. And by the way, this
mistake is also the reason why people
don't grow in general. Let me tell you a
story so you can better visualize what
I'm trying to say. Let's say you buy a
plant from the supermarket and you want
to plant it in your garden.
And this plant comes with instructions.
So, you go to the supermarket, you buy
the plant, and it comes with
instructions.
You go home,
you go to your garden, you unpack the
plant, and you read the instructions.
And the instructions are telling you
exactly what to do. They're telling you
how to take out the plant, how to dig a
hole in the soil for your plant, how to
put the plant, how to prepare the plant,
how to prepare the soil, and how to
water the plant. Basically, all the
instructions on how to grow this plant
are at your fingertips. And these
instructions are basically set in stone.
They are the system, right? They are the
thing that actually works. If you don't
respect them, the plant is going to die.
So, what you do, you read the
instructions, you put the plant, you do
everything right, and now you have the
plant. And the instructions say that you
should water this plant every single day
in the morning. So, what you do is you
water the plant, the next day you go and
you water the plant again, the next day
you go ahead and you water the plant
again. And let's say you do this for a
week. You water the plant every single
morning for a week, but you don't see
any progress. The plant isn't really
growing. It actually has one leaf
that is kind of dying. It's kind of
becoming yellow.
So, you start to get a little bit
frustrated. You start to worry a little
bit. Now, you're still not affected by
it. You still wake up the next day, and
you still water the plant. And you do it
for another week. But, the plant is
still not growing. At least you're not
seeing the progress. You're not seeing
the feedback. And because you're not
getting this feedback from the plant,
especially when you're following the
instructions, you bought this plant and
it came with instructions, which
promised you that the plant will grow.
What happens? One day, you're going to
wake up, and you're going to be busy to
work, or you're just going to have
something to do, and you're not going to
water the plant that day. You're just
going to tell yourself that this
isn't growing.
I'm just going to water it tomorrow.
And tomorrow you actually water the
plant. And then you water the plant the
day after tomorrow. But the plant is
still not really growing.
The leaf that was yellow is almost
falling apart. So what happens, you end
up not watering the plant for 2 days
because you start to get even more
frustrated and you start to tell
yourself that it's not going to work.
You followed the instructions but the
plant is not growing so I'm just going
to forget about it for 2 days because
I'm sad, I'm anxious, I'm angry, I'm
frustrated. And so what happens, you
develop this pattern where you water the
plant less and less and less to the
point where the plant actually dies. And
after this experience, you're going to
tell yourself that
plants are just not for you. You're
never going to buy plants again because
they're just you just can't grow them.
They they just hate you. That's what
you're going to tell yourself. But
here's the thing.
As you were watering the plant, the
plant actually was growing. It was
growing its roots
in the ground.
Because before the plant starts to grow
for you to actually see it, it has to
create the core. It has to create its
roots. So every day when you were
watering this plant, the plant was
actually growing.
You just wasn't seeing it. And this
happens because the plant has to grow at
its own rate. You can't force external
things to grow faster just because you
have instructions. But because you don't
see the growth, because you don't see
the feedback, and you become impatient,
and you start to develop anxiety, and
you start to kind of hate yourself, you
start to neglect the plant. And
eventually the plant dies. Well, that's
exactly how growing a YouTube channel
is, how growing a personal brand is, and
how growing a business is in general.
When you first start out, every single
video you make, every single post you
make, every single adjustment in your
business you make, everything you learn
about YouTube or your business or your
personal brand
is building the roots. You don't see
them, but they're building. Now, you
might be asking yourself, what exactly
is the lesson here? Is the lesson just
that I have to never give up?
Actually not. The lesson here is
actually way deeper, and it's something
I have learned about myself and I see in
other people. You see, it was never
about the plant. It was never about the
instructions. You see, the plant was
actually growing. The instructions on
how to grow the plant
also worked. So, the problem wasn't the
plant or the instructions. The problem
was you. The problem is you. And this is
the biggest mistake I see people make
when they want to create their own
personal brand, their own business
YouTube channel, their YouTube channel,
their business, whatever they want to
create. They focus so much on the
external thing without focusing on them.
What do I mean by that? Well, you can
learn as much as you want about
thumbnails, about click-through rate,
about retention, video editing. All
those things are the instructions on how
to grow the plant. But, if you don't
learn how to control your emotions, how
to control yourself, how to deal with
these feelings of frustrations and
anxiety, you will always quit when you
don't get feedback. And I've noticed
that in myself as well. Some of the
successful channels I talk about didn't
grow overnight. The journey was actually
kind of rough. What happened?
I created a channel, I posted videos for
3 weeks, I didn't really get
subscribers, and I quit. But, lucky for
me, a few months later, I started again,
and I posted more videos. But, I still
didn't get enough feedback, but I did
get some extra views and some extra
subscribers. But, because it wasn't
enough, it wasn't enough feedback for
for I also quit again for a few months.
But again, lucky for me, I always came
back and I always came back and I kept
working on the channel and improving to
the point where it actually started
getting momentum and it's starting
working. So basically, what was
happening during this time was I wasn't
actually learning so much about the
channel as I was actually learning more
about myself. I was learning that if I
actually don't quit and I put in the
time and I evolve and I improve,
eventually it should work out more or
less. And I personally believe it was
really important for me to talk about
this because I think this is the most
important thing when it comes to growing
on YouTube or your business, whatever.
You need to learn about yourself first.
You need to learn about your emotions.
You need to learn how to control your
emotions because if you're not able to
control yourself, if you're not able to
control your emotions, you will always
quit. You will always make decisions
based on emotions. And because of this,
you end up
killing the plant. Now, I know a lot of
you who have clicked on this video were
hoping for me to say something like,
"Use this keyword in your title
and you're going to get more views." The
thing is, I felt it was necessary to
start a video by talking about this
because it doesn't matter how much you
optimize your thumbnail, your
click-through rate, your retention, your
video editing skills, whatever, if you
don't work on yourself,
your business will never succeed. You
first have to work on yourself before
you work on your business. Now, as I
said, a lot of you probably clicked on
this video because you were hoping for
me to give you like a system, like the
specific thing that is going to get you
more views, and I do have a few of
those. They're more general
and they're something I have noticed in
the past 10 years that everyone is
doing, whether consciously or
unconsciously, and it grows their
channels. These are basically some
patterns I've observed on my channels,
on other channels, and they seem to
always work. No matter how many
algorithm changes there are, no matter
your niche, no matter your topic, no
matter your style, no matter who you
are, these patterns have always worked
on YouTube, on my channels, and on other
channels. So, in this video I want to
talk about these patterns, so you can
better understand how you can grow your
channel in a practical way. Now, by the
way, they're all super simple. Like,
when I'm going to talk about them,
you're going to be like, "What? This is
a secret?" Yeah, this is literally the
secret. You either listen to me, or you
just think you're super smart and leave
the video, right? But if you really want
to grow, listen to this, no matter how
simple it sounds. And for this first
pattern, which I use on my own channels,
and I see other creators use, and it
works really well. Like, when you use
this pattern in your videos, you almost
always get more views and get more
subscribers. And I want to tell a story
about it, so you can better understand
how it works before I actually show you
the pattern. So, last year, for example,
in real life,
there was a trend about chocolate. For
years, people have always
eaten chocolate, right? But last year, a
very specific type of chocolate became
popular. And it was this Dubai
chocolate, which was a little bit
different. Had different stuff inside,
right? And everyone was talking about
this chocolate. And so, imagine there
are two online stores, online websites,
who sell chocolate. One of them was
aware of this trend with Dubai
chocolate, and it started selling Dubai
chocolate. Because of that, the sales
went bazooka. Okay? It just started
selling way more. And the other store
decided not to sell Dubai chocolate.
They were like, "Nope, I'm not going to
sell this." This is super basic, right?
The reason why the store who started
selling Dubai chocolate sold more was
because Dubai chocolate was very
trending. Everyone was talking about it,
and so everyone wants to try it. Not
because it's better, not because it's
different, just simply because when
everyone talks about something, people
will want to try it out. And it's so
simple, right? This is such a simple
thing. When someone talks about
something, it becomes a trend. And if
you create videos about that trend, or
if you create a business around that
trend, chances are your business is
going to grow much faster. And it
actually is. Like whenever there's a
trend on YouTube, if you're able to
incorporate that trend in your videos,
you are going to grow faster. And this
is this first pattern that always seems
to work. It's trends. If you're able to
understand how to incorporate trends in
your videos without leaving your niche,
without going too far away from your
niche, you are going to succeed on
YouTube. And I want to give you a few
examples of how this works. For example,
let's say the movie Shrek 5 is coming
out at the end of this year or next
year, I don't know, but a lot of people
are waiting for it. So, how can you
incorporate this
in your videos? Well, let's say you
record and prepare a video to post 2
weeks before the movie gets out. And
let's say you're a cooking channel. What
can you do? Well, you can make a cake
that looks like Shrek or his entire
family. And you record the entire time
lapse of creating this cake, and you
make a story around it. You're still
inside your niche, which is cooking, but
you're using something popular everyone
is talking about to incorporate in your
video. Now, let's say you're a Minecraft
channel. You can create a Shrek painting
inside Minecraft. Or you can recreate
the entire Shrek village inside
Minecraft. And you say, "I recreated a
Shrek 5 village." And you post it right
before the movie gets out. So, you can
be creative and find your own ways to
incorporate something that's trending in
your own videos. Now, if you simply
can't, for example, maybe your niche is
very specific and you just can't
incorporate Shrek in your videos, don't
worry because Shrek is not the only
thing trending. There are always lots of
things trending on the internet. You
just have to find the one that fits with
your niche, with your channel, and add
it in your videos, and keep doing that.
And every single time you do that, you
will just boost your channel a little
bit more and a little bit more. And if
it doesn't work out this time, let's say
you do the Shrek 5 one, and it doesn't
work out, it's okay. Try another one
next month, and another one next month
until you actually reach that one viral
video, which will boost your channel,
which will create that momentum in your
channel. I know it sounds so simple, but
what's crazy is that I have a community
with people where I help them grow, and
I see almost no one do this. And even
with people who are subscribed to my
channel over here on Deny Why, I look at
your comments, I check your channels
sometimes, and none of you are doing
this. None of you have no idea how to
run trends, right? How to add trends to
your channel. And this is the first and
most important pattern I have seen on
YouTube to work for more than 15 years.
Every time you implement this pattern
the right way on your channel, you're
almost always going to grow. And if you
go to your favorite YouTubers, such as
Mr. Beast, you will see that his most
popular video is about Squid Games
because Squid Games was a very popular
series on Netflix, and so he made a
video about it. YouTubers with 50
million views who do vlogs for kids,
you'll always see them recreate popular
things from Roblox that are trending
inside Roblox, and so on. Once you
understand this, you will see it all
over YouTube. For example, a Faces
documentary channel will sometimes
create a documentary that gets 10
million views in just 2 weeks. For
example, when the Donald Trump shooting
happened, you had 3D history channels
create documentaries around it already
showcasing how it happened or whatever.
And I know a lot of you watching this
are like,
"This is so basic, like trends." But
you're you're still blind to it and you
don't see it. Once you open your eyes
and you see it, you will realize that
the entire YouTube is built around
trends. Every single successful
channels, every single successful
channel is using trends to grow. Now,
you don't always have to use trends in
every single video, but when there is a
trend, use it because it's going to
boost your channel. This is way more
important than click-through rate and
thumbnail and retention because these
things are just analytics. They do
represent how much people spend on your
video, but if you want people to spend
time on your video in the first place,
you must get them interested. But how do
you get them interested if you have just
10 subscribers, your videos are a little
bit shitty, and in your videos you just
talk about yourself, or you talk about
things you think people are going to be
interested. So, you see how you're
making it so hard for people to watch
your channel. First of all, they never
saw your videos before. They have no
idea who you are, so there's no trust
built there. There's no connection with
you. Second of all, they have so many
other options, so many other creators
making the same videos you're making,
and they're probably better than yours.
So, it's like why should anyone click on
your video, right? Well, if you use
trends, at least people are interested
in the trend. And if you have a nice
personality, or if you have a unique
editing style, or if you just get lucky
and people click on your video first
instead of clicking on other video, your
video might be the one that actually
gets viral. That is why trends are like
the core of growing on YouTube. I know
it sounds completely basic, and that's
because it actually is basic, and it
works.
It is what it is. Now, there is a second
pattern I have discovered that works
really well, and
basically, if you use this first pattern
and this second pattern, you will
eventually grow. Now, the second pattern
brings us back to the plant. If you're
able to work on yourself, if you're able
to control your emotions, if you're able
to just
be unemotional about your channel, about
your personal brand, about your
business, and just do it. Just continue
to do it, you will basically activate
this second pattern. And what the second
pattern is is basically taking care of
that plant until it actually grows
outside as well, not only the roots. So
now you're probably asking yourself,
what is this second pattern? Is it
consistency? I just have to keep
watering the plant again and again? It's
not really consistency. It's not about
consistency. It's about evergreen
content. Right? So think about this
plant I've talked about in the beginning
as evergreen content. Once it grows,
it's just going to continue to grow.
Every now and then rain is going to fall
on it, so it's going to get water
without you watering it. It's going to
get better at getting nutrients from the
ground because the roots grow a lot. So
what happens, it becomes
autonomous and evergreen. The plant just
sits there and lives there. And this is
exactly how evergreen content works.
Instead of spending one day on creating
one quick video, spend two weeks or
three weeks or even one month on a
video. Even if you post that video and
it gets zero views, just be unemotional
about it and continue to make these
types of videos. Because if you use the
first pattern and the second pattern,
eventually it's going to work out
because what happens, based on my own
experience, you create evergreen
content. And for those of you who don't
know what evergreen content means, it's
basically content that will continue to
grow 5 years later, 10 years later, and
so on. So evergreen content is basically
rewatchable content and also content
that is always relevant, right? You can
make the video today, but people are
going to want to watch it even 5 years
later. But the problem with evergreen
content is that it doesn't get views
instantly. It's content that slowly
grows, just like the a
But the thing is, when you make one
video, two videos, three videos, four
videos, and you do it for 3 4 years,
you're going to get like a catalog of
evergreen videos that are slowly going
to grow and grow and grow. And your
channel is just going to go faster and
faster and faster. And that's how these
channels end up having 2 million, 5
million, 10 million subscribers because
they use these two patterns. One of them
is evergreen content, so you just build
a catalog on your channel of quality
content. You don't care about the views.
You don't care how many views you get
this month or this year on that video.
You just think about the video itself.
You want it to make sure it's good, it's
rewatchable, it's relatable, it's
up-to-date every time, it stays
evergreen. And if you have that, and
then you use the first pattern to
sometimes create videos around trends,
you basically have the formula of
growing on YouTube. That's it. Now,
don't get me wrong. It This doesn't mean
that thumbnails don't matter or
click-through doesn't matter. They
matter, but they don't matter as much as
they're being pushed. First of all,
those things changed. Whatever you might
learn about thumbnails this year is
going to change next year, right? And
this is basically the last thing I have
learned about YouTube, which is also
incredibly important. You need to
understand that every single advice on
YouTube is general. For example, if I'm
going to tell you a type of titles, what
type of thumbnails work for my channel
Danny Wy,
it's most likely not going to work for
your channel. And the confusing part
here is that my advice is going to be
good, right? Because it works for me.
The type of thumbnails I create for
Danny Wy, the type of titles I create
for Danny Wy, they work for me. So, I
have proof it works. So, here, take it.
It works. But, the thing is, it's not
going to work for you. You have a
different channel, a different niche.
It's just advice on YouTube is very
general. And what happens if you're
going to listen to advice from him and
her and me, you're going to have this
confusion in your head and it's going to
be like you don't know what works
anymore. And the thing is, and the
beauty about YouTube, by the way, is
that once you spend enough time with
your channel and you apply these
patterns so you grow a little bit, you
will slowly learn what actually works
for you, what type of viewers actually
watch your channel. And once you
understand that, you'll know exactly
what type of thumbnails you should make
for your channel. Not only that, but you
will learn how to improve your
thumbnails for your channel. Like,
listen, this right here is probably the
most important thing I'm going to say in
this entire video.
Do you think
I go on YouTube and watch tutorials
about click-through rate and retention
and how to improve my thumbnails?
I don't. The reason why I'm able to make
thumbnails people click, the reason I'm
able to have a good click-through rate,
is because I have learned my own channel
and my own audience. And I just know
what works for me. I have no idea if
other channels inside my niche, which
are competitors, have higher
click-through rate or if they have
higher average view duration. I have no
idea. And honestly, I don't care
because I know what works for me, I know
what are my numbers, and could they be
bigger? Could they be lower? Yes, but
the thing is it works and I discovered
that myself for my channel. If I go
ahead now and I watch some person
telling me how to improve my
click-through rate, chances are my
click-through rate is actually going to
drop because I know my channel much
better than a random guru on YouTube
does. So, if you want to grow on
YouTube, you need to study you,
right? Your channel, you. Not other
people's channel, not some guru telling
you what's working for him because
what's working for him, it's working for
him. What's working for you is going to
work for you. But now you're probably
going to ask yourself, wait, so why
should you listen to me if I shouldn't
listen to other gurus? Because in this
video, I'm not talking about
click-through rate. I'm not talking how
to improve your thumbnail. What I'm
talking about it's much deeper. These
are patterns, these are behaviors, these
are things that simply seem to work.
This is not a system. I have no idea how
you should incorporate the trend on your
channel. That's something you have to
find for yourself. I can't tell you
that. All I can tell you is that this is
what works. So, just do this. Just do
these four things. I don't care what
click-through rate you have. I don't
care how your thumbnails look. Just do
these four things. Take care of yourself
and improve yourself first. Understand
trends and how to incorporate them in
your own videos and then create just
evergreen videos. Just create evergreen
videos even if they don't get views. 2
years later, 3 years later, they are
going to get views because they're
evergreen. Literally one random day, the
YouTube algorithm will be like, "Let's
just give views to this video." And
you'll be shocked. You'll be like,
"Whoa, I literally forgot about this
video and out of nowhere it's getting
200,000 views." And then, study
yourself. Look at yourself. Look at your
channel. Look at your subscribers. And
all those four things, they work with
each other and they're like a symbiotic
thing. So, I hoped this helped. Now, if
you're still struggling to pick your
niche and create ideas for your YouTube
channel, you might want to watch this
video over here because inside this
video